mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
an octagon with equal side lengths is
made by cutting the corners of a
rectangle with side lengths of four and
six as shown in the diagram
what is the side length of the octagon
i thank bhanwari for sending me a
similar problem on twitter at presh
talwalkar
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so let's solve this problem
we'll label the side length of the
octagon by the letter s
we'll label these two lengths as y
and these two lengths as x
now suppose this side of the rectangle
has a length of four
that means two x plus s is equal to four
the other side length will be equal to
six and that means two y plus s is equal
to six
now consider this corner of the
rectangle
it's a right triangle and therefore x
squared plus y squared is equal to s
squared
we thus have a system of three equations
in the first equation we'll solve for x
in the second equation we'll solve for y
and then we'll substitute these values
into the third equation
the result will be a quadratic equation
in the variable s
we'll solve this systematically
we'll first multiply both sides by 4
then we'll expand each binomial and
collect like terms we'll divide this
equation by 2 and then we'll use the
quadratic formula to get two values for
s
but remember s is a side length so we
want s to be greater than zero so we'll
reject the negative solution and we get
s is equal to negative five plus the
square root of 51 which is approximately
2.14 and that's the answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you